hallo mein Name ist Luca und meine Damen
und Herren seitdem ich YouTube-Videos
mache hatte ich irgendwie noch nie ein
richtiges Intro für meinen Kanal von
daher habe ich mir gedacht Mensch
wie kannst du Intros kriegen aber keinen
Cent dafür ausgeben ihr
kostet nichts mach das für mich schickt
mir das zu und ich spar die Tausende von
Euros die sonnenkranker Intro
3d-hersteller abknüpfen wollte letzte
Woche von daher meine Damen und Herren
haben diese drei Instagram Fanpages von
mir sich hingesetzt in den letzten Tagen
und haben die besten Youtube Intros
zusammengebastelt die ist auch nur geben
kann ihr könnt unten in den Kommentaren
abstimmen welches Sie am besten findet
und wir starten direkt mit Nummer eins
das war's
wir lassen uns davon allerdings gar
nicht Beeren und machen direkt weiter
mit Intro Nummer 2
[Musik]
scheiß ich heiße nicht loser eigentlich
als ich laserluca
auch vorbei das war besser als das erste
aber irgendwie habt ihr meinen Namen
falsch geschrieben also das heißt Laser
und nicht Loser
[Musik]
danke
wenigstens wurde ich jetzt richtig
geschrieben das hier ist Intro Nummer 4
und es hat was zu tun mit meinem
Skyblock Intro vielleicht ist es ein
Edith ich klick auf Play
ich habe gerade einen neuen Partner
gefunden für meine YouTube-Videos und
die Vermarktung erzähle sich denn denken
[Musik]
ich
kennt ihr das wenn ihr so traurig seid
dass ihr einfach lachen müsst wie kann
es denn sein das andere Youtuber wie so
ein rezo oder so ein Julien BAM wenn die
so Aufrufe machen das deren Community
was er schaffen soll dass da so richtig
Kranke Meisterwerke bei rumkommen und
bei mir wird so eine Klopapierrolle mit
meinem Gesicht drauf geklebt und
irgendwie mit Paint hier Laser Luca kurz
mal reingeschrieben was auch noch
komplett schief ist
[Musik]
[Applaus]
also wir haben jetzt zwei Möglichkeiten
entweder ich nutze jetzt irgendeins von
diesen Intros und kann meinen Kanal in
drei vier Wochen
zu machen weil mich keiner mehr gucken
wird
oder ich lösche meinen Kanal jetzt schon
warum
laserlaka
loser Luca laserlacka
[Musik]
warum K
Leute Laser Luca
ist es denn so schwer
was ist das
ich kacke in meinen Arsch
[Musik]
mach Ende ich will nicht mehr
das war's
[Musik]
ich wäre gerade lieber
Atlantik
umgeben von den gefährlichsten Haien
Krokodilen und Wasserschlangen die es
gibt als dass ich mir hier weiter diese
Intros anschaue
[Musik]
ja
es war klar
es war doch klar
sorry aber
wenn ein Unternehmen
irgendwann noch mal mit mir eine Korb
machen will wenn die einmal dieses Video
sehen ich bin raus
sorry dass ich so lustig bin allergisch
gegen dumme Intros
ist vorbei
mittlerweile sind an dem Punkt angelangt
wo tatsächlich nicht mal mehr Text
vorkommt in der Küche Chips
richtig witzig gewesen wenn sie einfach
nicht getroffen wird
es ist 3:30 Uhr
nachts und ich finde
ich bin verzweifelt
[Musik]
bisher mein Favorit Leute
nicht mit K
bin ich das als Papierflieger
ich gucke die Intros ja voller
Lautstärke unter mir weil mein Nachbarn
die haben neugeborenes Kind das pennt
ich habe gesagt ich nehme leise auf und
ich werde nach was mache ich ich nehme
laut auf Mitten um 3:30 Uhr
ich bin Zug
in diesem Intro
mit K mal wieder
es ist doch einfach zum Mäuse melken
hier mit euch
abonniert laserluca
die Abo
net laserluca
guck mal wenn es um deabonnieren geht
werde ich dann plötzlich wieder richtig
geschrieben ne super letztes Intro
werde ich ein ich werde eingesaugt ja
Freunde
ich glaube mein Kanal